[Musik]
oskar freysinger die sportpolitiker und
folter der 52-jährige volkstribun setzt
zu seinem grössten sprung an
[Musik]
freysinger polarisiert seit jahren
und da ist es auch schon vorgekommen
dass man sein haus angezündet hat
so geschehen vor zehn jahren nachdem er
mit einem politischen gewicht
schlagzeilen machte sagen sie denn nicht
wie selbst sondern um wo man jetzt hatte
ich große aktion ins ohr gezündet
wodurch ein drittel job geplant der
winter kalt und die strecke vom dach und
in stockach darum brauchen sie dennoch
weiter denn mit dem schlafmittel geparkt
obwohl die damals überlebte mit politik
nichts am hut
die handwerker screen jetzt aufklären
wenn du jetzt ist das ist es verheerend
signal für dieses land das genügt also
dass man irgendwo wird gegen politiker
und der heftigste einfach alle die die
ideologisch die dieses verstand ist vom
staat oder der hilfe war für nur wenn
wir die qualität angeht dass die
darstellt welche gewollt dass dort etwas
niederschlag überhaupt sehen ist der
streitbare politiker zu hause jetzt
wieder ganz nach oben in die walliser
regierung dann muss es eine leere stelle
aufgeben
genau am große zimmer bin intrinsischen
kinder worte kommen also die erste 23
shirley und bitte ich sie und jetzt
zwölf jahre später ja nicht ganz
speziell abstriche machen
aber da sagt man sind wir jetzt hier
später bin ich jetzt hier schon
eingebaut
oskar freysinger will aufräumen mit den
linken und netten mit den fischen und
gutmenschen mit den fremden und staat
saugen
mit leidenschaft ist der deutsch lehrer
am gymnasium von sie den jungen welchen
bringt der deutsche literatur näher
klassische werte und auch eigene ergüsse
ein kreis den einstmals auf den strich
den kreis zu sein war ärgerlich er
hüpfte auf eine gerade doch diesen
wiederum war schade denn unter ihm bog
sich der strich die beiden enden fanden
sich und schon was mit dem strich vorbei
dafür gab es da kreise 2 und die moral
davon sucht zur erlösung von der norm
dann lasst dem anderen seine form
freysinger ist ein ausgebuffter
rattenfänger er ist einer dem vielleicht
auch ich auf den leim kriechen werde
mich fasziniert seine leidenschaft für
die literatur aber genauso stößt mich
seine rechtsradikal etap linkes gesindel
und zwar nicht dass es so gemeint von
damme heraus chemiker schön gemacht
hätte und mit der schulwahl und mache
ich habe das nicht akzeptieren dass die
schüler im namen von den lich stelle im
grund nur ein absoluter fläche gestellt
und doch sind die theorien die rcs
theorie für die 60er jahre wo man
irgendwie gewisse opponiert hat wissen
ist zu später stunde es ist sowieso
alles im internet die so sollen die
schüler neuerdings kommt der volt auf
leisen pfoten daher der rattenfänger
macht auf schmusekurs
auch wenn er energisch gegen alle 68er
methoden antritt er will das ruder
herumreißen
schule und gesellschaft ausmisten die
jungs nichts sind wunderschöne die
freisinger weiß wie er seine walliser um
den finger wickeln kann ein lungen und
austeilen gegen aussen
heute sind die schafzüchter an der reihe
aufräumen will er auch mit der allmacht
von christoph blocher doch davon später
spricht um das ist jetzt wartet das 4
zurück auf die gründung von der
eidgenossenschaft ist der friedhof
schienen grund und boote sagen wenn wir
die landwirtschaft echelon wird schon
mit schützen
er habe das problem mit der zeit geht
viel wissen verloren viel know-how das
anfänglich und und das haben wir dann
gibt es schnell wieder wenn es der
plötzlichen salate und ich glaube wir
stehen in der großen krise globale krise
zu
und da jetzt ermöglichen wie es nützlich
sie wenn man der video selber
produzieren nicht nur importieren
freysinger nämlich mit auf seinen
wahlkampf durch so oberwallis
jahresversammlung der chef noch regieren
hier die schwarzen die cvp der svp
provokateur will diese allmacht knapp in
bern die haben wir darüber dass zu kurz
gekommene wallis und im wallis schimpft
er über die in bayern oben und öfters
mal schreitet über den wolf das raubtier
das von den geschätzt wird
freysinger ist wieder chef noch jährigen
in der natur ist der im wohnmobil
unterwegs
hier ist der berufs provokateur zu hause
in salehs oberhaupt jung wohnt der vater
von vier erwachsenen kindern je frau
schießen schießen macht alle
internetauftritte für oskar sie ist
hausfrau musical regisseurin und seit
einem jahr wahlkampfleiterin für ihren
mann
seit dem brandanschlag auf ihr haus ist
ehefrau schließlich die wichtigste
beraterin von moskau
[Musik]
grafik
online wahrscheinlich wie silikone nie
aber sie aber nicht ein bisschen angst
wenn sie jetzt so gut wahlkampf machen
für die ihren mann dass er nachher gar
nicht mehr zweifel es ist schon 13 jahre
jahren ungefähr dass er ist viel besetzt
aber er hat immer zeit gefunden
für und die familie wenn man so schöne
frau hat ist das kein grund man immer t
notiert sein und mich mit in den
untergrund oscar ist er als sohn eines
österreichers und einer walliserin
aufgewachsen ist das erste
wilhelminischen deutschland
da bin ich als unsere sonne sehr
botenstoffs gestellt und und dann
herrschte nur die die flocke koffer
deiner schiffen und das ist ja auch
schön kunden wenn man es noch nie sagt
was sie politisch konkret siege feiern
senat den antrieb der herr freysinger
ist eine wowi fast reflexartig gegen
friends reagiert das ist aber sehr
komische hitler über die auf die eigene
logik vor den medien
das sieht sonst wird man produziert im
logo und der salbe droht der stände
reproduzieren ich bin ein großer
bewunderer funktion buddhismus zum
beispiel ich bin eine gruppe für tibet
ich bin in der gruppe für taiwan will
die bienen sich noch fertig sind format
oder italien steht ich mein gott ich
habe freunde sind so verändert haben
mit dem best findet in selb und der
zweistündigen roman also oberhalb
mitglied vom selben autor war dass ich
mir absolut woher ist genauso stolz
seine wurzel ist genauso schön identität
runaway aber wenn man hier das sammeln
aber harmonisch wild war leichter
insbesondere wenden oder des gewissens
religiöses dogma heißt wir den islam
gewisse abstriche und eine grauzone
macht und wenn du das nicht will mache
den helfer das problem will der kunde
mit dem rechtsstaat in dem konflikt
darum habe sich bei der
minarett-initiative ganz mächtig ins
zeug werfen müssen sagt wie der sv
wähler seine politik muss ich habe die
frage gefallen lassen wie viele
rassismus steckt da drin ist diesem mann
sein vorbild der rechtsextreme holländer
geert wilders mit fremdenfeindlichen
parolen hat der ein drittel im parlament
geruht darauf holte freisinger mit dem
holländer in der schweiz auftreten in
lotte damit schien ihm eh nix sagen wir
so ich meine ich
linksextreme leute und deren in ihrem
salon der schnitt dem rechtsstaat
widersprachen will niemanden kunden
zählt man dafür eine frische spur ändern
würde auch das problem das ist das ist
ganz klar das widerspricht dem
rechtsstaat dass das ist allerdings kein
bock sich auch gegen christoph blocher
durch gegen den widerstand von blocher
wurde freisinger in die schweizerische
parteileitung gewährt der svp übervater
bis dahin gezählt
obwohl in herzprobleme belassen hat er
noch großes vor
sie bereitet sich auf trawler von königs
worten vor ich glaube ich würde da und
wurde wehrte der gandhi wenn die andere
hand in die verlauten
wir begleiten sie die alte freunde zum
ausgang hatte sondern am stiel nirgends
das heißt sie wenden
vorher ist noch wahlkampf im wallis ring
frei für oskar und seinen gegenspieler
christian warum herrscht ein frauen aus
der türkei
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
freysinger verspricht den wallisern in
der erziehungsdirektion aufzuräumen
das linke gesindel wie er die 68er
pädagogen ja nennt wird sich noch die
augen reiben
er war um für sie war das irgendwie ein
logische karriereschritt vom polizei
kommen dann quasi eine stufe höher ist
das der grund dass sich dafür werden
wollen ich bin ich immer für das wurde
bei dieser bevölkerung eingesetzt
das ist mein großes interesse und jetzt
mit dieser funktion als staatsrat ich
diese möglichkeit den ball ist noch
besser zu dienen
es ist meine wirklich wahre motivation
dienen und karriere machen das natürlich
auch das ganz genau das darf man schon
der polizei ist es normal noch eine
karriere auf französisch steinbruch
also dachten
[Applaus]
franke hatte ich den eindruck sie haben
sich sehr viel mühe gegeben sich so als
sehr friedlich und als seriös
aufzustellen heute auch im zweireiher
nicht in der lederjacke ich habe sehr
viel getan was sie so in einem anderen
licht erscheinen
ist das eine strategie von ihnen eine
rasche es haben es viele menschen nicht
gemerkt als ich 2008 zusammengebrochen
bin und vier stunden im koma war und
dann wieder erwachte
da hat der freisinger wahrscheinlich
eine etappe seines lebens überschritten
die ihn zu etwas neuem geführt hat
früher war ich schon dafür auch allein
mal hamburg gewählt zu europa nicht aber
jetzt haben wir die prioritäten richtig
setzen wenn es vielleicht nicht so
scheint mir ein bisschen langsamer im
tempo durchs leben gehen aber immer
scheint es ja nicht so zu sein sie haben
immerhin und woche wieder attraktiver
parkiert erst kürzlich wegen der minute
initiative sie haben sich offenbar aus
dem spital via skype in einer
medienkonferenz eingeschaltet also so
ganz vorbei ist dieser provokateure doch
noch nicht aber sehen sie wenn sie gegen
einen losziehen der schlimmer ist als
sie sind dann ist das nicht so schlimm
oskar schreibt eigene lieder und
komponiert die musik dazu ja ganze
musicals die seine frau dann inszeniert
sie waren drei für einen schwur drei
kleine schweizer bauern nur ihr durst
nach freiheit war es so groß er lässt
bis heute uns nicht los
deuce
[Musik]
freysinger will us-künstler durchgehend
bisher hat der neue bücher verfasst
gedichte und romane deutsch und
französisch gerade konnte seinen roman
als drehbuch nach hollywood verkaufen
sobald die 50 millionen dollar zusammen
sind seit drehbeginn wie findet oscar
bloß zeit auch noch durch den literatur
zirkus zu singen dann stehen sie als
erste menschen auf dem berg wo blitz und
donner mit dem echo spielen wer über
riesensieg das nimmer mehr ein zwerg
denn größe misst sich an der anzahl
spielen durch mühsal wächst der mensch
über sich selbst hinaus es ist nicht
darum der ihn zum sieger kürt ein
gipfelstürmer schert sich niemals um
applaus es zählt allein der weg der ihn
nach oben führt einen oskar freysinger
jedenfalls auf sicher der zukünftige
hollywood star reist vws der einmal
nachbarn in den nationalrat
am morgen ging dann ein paar geschäfte
im parteipräsidium dazwischen ein wenig
dichten wald kommt noch ein volk dazu
regierungsrat wer ist das
oskar freysinger wer sich selber
manchmal friedliebende shankly sehr
literarisch interessiert und und und und
schöpferisch eine bewusst ein
hyperaktiver man die andere manchem
mittels als als selbstzweck betrachtet
und nicht als mittel
ich habe in der partei gehen wir das
nicht manche nahe und erfordere
manche hätten ihn erwartet jetzt jedoch
haben der trägen strom mabis bringen als
gläubiger katholik hat freisingerin der
cvp begonnen
der weg an die sonne blieben bei den
christlichen aber versperrt
so gründete er vor 14 jahren kurzerhand
die svp wallis seine schlitzohrigkeit
macht ihn nicht unsympathisch wenn mir
gar nicht die geschichte mit porto
luzide ziel kommen würde
ist oskar freysinger also doch ein
rattenfänger
ausgerechnet gegen parteikollege toni
bortoluzzi reimte er etwas von gott zum
fuji zusammen ein break machte dieses
war poesie sagt sein bewacher windet
sich albert freisinger spreche mit
seiner frau halt meist französisch und
darum habe er nicht gewusst dass sie
nicht so schädlich sei sagt mit der
schließung
das problem ist wenn erst nachträglich
gemacht im schweizer dialekt herrscht
das neue womit er früher weggeht wo das
b 252 hemd und im oberwallis und er hat
das cockpit geworden
und darum bin ich irgendwie ins rotieren
das hat nichts mit dem französischen
staat mit dem motto walliser tschopp dem
sich text alemannisch gegen hoch aber
ich werde ich mich aber dann hätten wir
den blick ganze woche lang fertig
gemacht und am samstag hätte mich
ausgebrannt
ich ziehe ein quiz stolzes und sagte mir
in der literatur schon ein wenig dichter
egal wo wir ihn haben den brandanschlag
noch zeitgemäß aber das ist ja immerhin
schon ab ist also noch mal in den bauch
so schließt sich nun der kreis für
freysinger ist am ziel
die walliserin letzten sonntag in den
staatsrat gewählt mit einem
traumresultat
der provokateur zieht in die walliser
regierung ein
aber bei genauerem beobachten
hört man den staatsrat schon mal wie
einen feinen herren sprechen das ist nun
ins exekutive ist sie aber ich waren
dann wohl komplett abstrich gemacht
inhaltlich es ist nur die ordnung ist
und euch fotoshow es hat sich nicht
jetzt in der letzten woche kann dritte
missy may geschichten sind zwei drei
oder massiv gaben trittau wunderbar ist
will ich selber kaufen ort mit der
zitrone die erfahrung den kopf dass man
nicht unbedingt mit der tür ins haus
fallen dadurch ihre position im übrigen
hält die stadt für menschen in der lohn
hätte den sounds der wert legen ich bin
nicht das interesse nicht was heißt dass
manche sind kredite
ich habe einfach das ausgedrückt was die
liegt im grunde von politik
sind die wahllisten dem freisinger also
auf den leim gekrochen schafft tosca den
wandel vom provokateur zum staatsmann
wie viel kreide fressen oskar freysinger
antwortete darauf mit worten von bertolt
brecht
wir schauen tief betroffen
in vorhang zu und alle fragen offen
[Musik]